prime minister Rishi sunak has been
issued with a conditional offer a fixed
penalty by Lancashire constabulary for
failing to wear a seat belt while
filming this social media clip in the
back of a moving car yesterday you may
remember that was posted on social media
and the Prime Minister apologized for
not wearing a seat belt where he has now
been issued with a conditional offer a
fixed penalty by Lancashire constabulary
for failing to wear a seat belt
certainly the evidence was there the
Prime Minister acknowledged it and he
apologized for it and he's now been sent
a conditional offer of fixed penalty no
idea how much that will be but that is
the decision by Lancashire police
following that video filmed in the back
of a car on the prime minister's visits
to the north of England yesterday where
he wasn't wearing a seat belt he
apologized he acknowledged it and he's
now been issued with a conditional offer
of fixed of a fixed penalty and we can
go to our political correspondent Joe
Pike who is standing by for us at
Westminster Joe what more can you tell
us about this breaking news
well I don't think there was uh much uh
Richardson that could do in his defense
because he put his hands up and admitted
it pretty fast I think number 10 and
Lancashire police are Keen to move on
from this pretty quickly but it clearly
was as the PM admitted an error of
judgment it wasn't just that he wasn't
wearing a seat belt in his prime
ministerial car but that he that he
filmed it and then that was shared on
social media it seemed inevitable from
that moment on that the police would
have to give a fire and Lancashire
police as you say have released this
statement not naming Rishi sunak but
talking of a 42 year old man they said
on Twitter following the circulation of
a video on a social media showing an
individual failing to wear a seat belt
while a passenger in a moving current
Lancashire we have today Friday issued a
42 year old man from London with a
conditional offer of a fixed penalty
notice now Sky News has contacted a
number 10 for an official a response on
this story I'm sure they'll confirm that
contends to pay this conditional offer
of a fixed penalty a notice and moved on
of course it's the second time he's been
fined he got a fine around partygate
labor may use this to feed into the sort
of picture they try and create of a
government not necessarily always
adhering to the rules but Richard zunak
has tried to differentiate his
leadership and his Premiership from that
of some of his predecessors in
particular Boris Johnson he spoke about
wanting to provide a different level of
Integrity professionalism and
accountability when he was on the steps
of Downing Street on day one and I'm
sure his willingness to put his hands up
quickly admit wrongdoing and move on is
part of that that attempt number 10 I
think we'll be pleased that this has
been dealt with before the weekend
before Sunday political shows before
Sunday papers and I think they'll be
hoping voters forget about it soon too
yes certainly Joe I think they'll hope
that this is the line under it as you
say thanks very much indeed for the
update thank you